en el vídeo pasado llegamos a esta
expresión del volumen que era el volumen
de este sonido de revolución que yo
tengo aquí arriba que se parece un tazón
un poco extraño pero justo atrás de
estos lo que voy y entonces lo que vamos
a hacer en este vídeo es resolver esta
integral y para esto lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es este binomio al
cuadrado perfecto por lo tanto me va a
quedar pi que multiplica a la integral
evaluada desde ya igual a menos 1 hasta
igual a 3 de todo esto que tengo aquí
que es un binomio cuadrado perfecto por
lo tanto me queda cuadrado del primero
cuadrado con la raíz se va y me queda
más uno después es dos veces el primero
por el segundo es decir dos por dos es
cuatro por la raíz de ye más uno y
después me queda cuadrado el segundo que
es más cuatro y bueno todo esto
multiplicado por de james y se dan
cuenta se puede simplificar un poco
porque uno más cuatro me dan cinco
entonces estos dos los voy a sumar y me
dan cinco y ahora sí voy a resolver esta
integral y para esto voy a buscar las
anti derivadas respectivas entonces
déjame ponerlo ya en un corchete porque
es lo que voy a evaluar
veamos me va a quedar la anti derivada
de apuesta es muy fácil cuadrada entre 2
después a esto hay que agregarle la anti
derivada de cuatro veces la raíz de ye
más uno pero esto sale por sustitución
porque esta expresión es lo mismo que
decir que tengo cuatro veces que
multiplica ye más uno elevado a la un
medio y podríamos decir que lo de aquí
adentro es u pero como no está tan
difícil podemos calcular dvd una vez y
la diferencia el dvd lo que está que
adentro es simple y sencillamente de y
por lo tanto es una integral muy
sencilla y espero que tengas práctica
con esto lo único que hay que hacer es
sumarle uno al exponente es decir me va
a quedar ye más un elevado a la tres
medios y después x y esto multiplicado
por el recíproco de tres medios es decir
dos tercios pero dos tercios por cuatro
es lo mismo que ocho tercios entonces al
final me quedan ocho tercios que
multiplican a ye más uno elevado a la
tres medios espero que ya tengas más
práctica con esto y bueno después hay
que agregarle a esto la anti derivada de
5 de james
delante derivada de 5 day es una cosa
muy sencilla y simple sencillamente 5
veces y todo esto lo voy a evaluar desde
ye igual a menos 1 hasta igual a 3 desde
tres a menos uno y por lo tanto pues
vamos a seguir haciéndolo primero hay
que evaluar en tres por lo tanto me
queda pi que multiplica y ahora voy a
sustituir cualquier ye por tres entonces
me queda tres al cuadrado entre dos lo
cual son nueve medios más me queda tres
más uno elevado a tres medios es lo
mismo que cuatro elevado a tres medios y
si le sacamos la raíz a cuatro estos
elevado al cubo es 8 por 8 son 64
tercios más hay que agregarles 5 por 3
es decir más 15 3 por 5 es sí sí sí sí
es 15 y a todo esto a todo esto le voy a
quitar la evaluación en menos 1 entonces
me queda menos 1 elevado al cuadrado
entre 2 pues es lo mismo que un medio
esto está muy sencillo después menos uno
más uno es cero y cero elevado a lo que
sea es cero y cero por lo que sea es
cero por lo tanto todo esto cuando oye
es igual a menos uno se va se cancela y
al final me queda cinco por menos 15
15 y entonces lo único que tengo que
hacer es resolver estas respectivas
cuentas estas respectivas operaciones y
ya con esto encontraría el volumen que
yo quiero así que vamos a hacerlo
entonces me queda pi que multiplica y
voy a sacar el mínimo común múltiplo de
todos estos que tenemos aquí el común
denominador de 2 3 y 2 pues es 6
entonces voy a pasar 9 medios a sextos
que es lo mismo que multiplicar 3 por 9
que es 27 y abajo por 3 es decir 27
sextos más 64 tercios para pasar los
sextos es lo mismo que 128 sextos y
después 15 para pasar los sextos es lo
mismo que 90 sextos 6 por 15 es 90 y
después a esto hay que quitarle menos un
medio pero un medio escrito en sextos es
lo mismo que 3 sextos y después menos x
menos me da más y 5 escrito en sextos es
lo mismo que 6 por 5 30 30 sextos y
ahora si tengo escrito todo en sextos
por lo tanto ya puedo hacer la operación
de todo esto el denominador me va a
quedar 6 el resultado de toda esta
operación hay que multiplicarla por pi y
después dice
7 128 27 128 es 78 es quince llevamos
una dos y dos son cuatro y 15 y por lo
tanto me queda 155 en total 6 27 128 si
de aquí a camps son 155 entonces déjenme
escribirlo aquí
estos son 155 y después de que sumarle
el 90 155 más 90 también está fácil es
245 entonces hasta aquí llevamos 245 y
después le quitamos 3 a 245 le quitamos
3 pues me quedan 242 aquí no hay tanto
problema y a 242 le sumamos 30 pues
también está muy fácil esto es lo mismo
que 272 por lo tanto mi resultado final
son 272 y sextos pero creo que esto se
puede simplificar porque ambos son
divisibles entre 2 entonces le voy a
sacar mitad a ambos me queda la mitad de
272 es la mitad de dos es uno la mitad
de 72 es 36 entonces me queda 136 pi y
la mitad de 6 es 3
entonces me queda 136 pi tercios y 136
no es divisible entre 3 porque si
sumamos los dígitos no es divisible
entre 3 y es hora de sentirnos
orgullosos porque hemos acabado pues
aquí ya tenemos el volumen de nuestra
pequeña gomita volteada